straniero
ed è passione solo attrazione o è
anche azione beh
diamo un'occhiata alla definizione di
passione sai che ho iniziato dal latino e dal
greco quando traducevamo dal
latino e dal greco e il significato della parola è
molto importante quindi la passione è un
sentimento molto forte  capitale di
dominare completamente una persona che diciamo di te
sai accecato dalla Passione e ho una
passione per qualcuno che sai bene che è
Passione qualcosa che posso mostrarti posso
trasmetterti posso dimostrarlo bene non è così
facile quindi diamo un'occhiata di nuovo una
passione come  un'attrazione ed eccomi qui a
baciare una bellissima ragazza tipica
attrazione è così beh non è quello che
pensi perché in realtà si trattava di un
atto ripetuto molte volte senza alcuna
passione era totalmente falso era una pubblicità che
ho fatto l'unica volta che ero  davanti
all'obiettivo e credetemi era bellissima ma
non c'era passione eppure noi pensiamo che
questa sia passione
comunque vediamo un po' la passione
è un grande interesse questo
dice il dizionario beh sai che abbiamo la
passione della lettura  abbiamo una passione da
sostenere abbiamo una passione per la musica
abbiamo una passione per molte cose abbiamo una
passione per la pittura beh sai diamo
un'occhiata alla passione come interesse
ed eccomi qui, un bambino con una macchina fotografica,
puoi vedermi  non avevo nemmeno cinque
anni con mio fratello e avevo già la
passione per le immagini in movimento e soprattutto
per l'illuminazione dei movimenti e la creazione di
emozioni e questo era quello che volevo fare
era creare passione nelle immagini, nel
film ho lavorato e usare la luce per muovermi
le persone non creano immagini in movimento e
tu lo sai, permettimi e mi hai fatto
partecipare ad alcuni film fantastici,
sai Full Metal Jacket
007 Harry Potter, Robin Hood e così via
e ho creato questo lavoro, conosci questo
lavoro per via della mia passione, la mia passione
era l'azione,  la difficoltà è quando devo
spiegare anche quando vengo intervistato
cos'è questa passione e come posso
trasmetterla fidati di me non posso
saperlo nemmeno quando vado in televisione proprio
non riesco come posso farlo quindi sai
pensare  uh sì, dovremmo studiare
legge e l'ho fatto per qualche anno con te,
conosci anche alcuni esami, ma sai che
non era la mia passione, quindi la passione è un grande
interesse, diamo un'occhiata,
dipingere è la sua grande passione, andiamo  dai
un'occhiata a una delle sue passioni la mia passione
per la pittura L'ho dipinto quando avevo
12 anni e ho vinto un premio piuttosto importante
e dei soldi e con quello ho comprato
pennelli migliori, sai che la mia famiglia era
molto modesta e aveva colori migliori e un
macchina fotografica migliore perché ricorda che era la
mia grande passione e stavo cercando di
trasmettere la passione di una ballerina quando
balla e tutto questo lavoro dietro
ma sai che non era abbastanza quindi quello che ho
fatto dopo è stato cercare di trasmettere
la passione che vedo  agli occhi di
qualcuno come in questo caso o una passione passione
interiore un momento di passione ma
sai anche se mi vedi dipingere
sai che non vedi la passione oppure
vedi solo un pennello sulla tela e sai
dipingerti a secco  conosci la pittura che si
asciuga quindi potresti guardare uno dei miei
quadri e ti piacerà non ti
piace ma vedi la passione posso
darti la mia passione beh proviamo
qualcos'altro passione per la moto
questo è qualcosa di molto  di persone si
racconteranno ed eccola qui, nel 1951, una delle mie
primissime Vespe e sai che ho
sempre avuto una grande passione per il
cambiamento del profumo, dell'aria e del
senso di libertà nei grandi cieli anche su
America's Best Ma e lo sai sempre
stato  scrivendolo con molta attenzione e bene per la
maggior parte del tempo e um sai poi è
cambiato e lui ha iniziato ad appassionarsi alle
moto più grandi e ora ovviamente agli
stereotipi di Harley Davidson. Mi dispiace e uh in
realtà ho chiesto all'organizzatore del teatro
di fare un grande ingresso  con la mia Harley
ora hanno detto che è troppo rumorosa, sai che al
cinema non piacerà, ma non c'è rumore
ogni volta che la accendo, c'è musica e
DRM, sai, con un'altra passione che
è ovviamente la mia famiglia, ecco mia
figlia e um, sai la passione per
scrivere sai che ho scritto molti libri in
inglese e italiano e alcuni hanno avuto
molto successo e sono stato molto fortunato
in questo caso in particolare ha avuto anche
la professione di maurita costanzo
scomparsa di recente è stata una grande
perdita non solo per me ma  per vintaya
direi che l'Umanità è stata un grande grande
artista e creativo ed è stato molto
fortunato ma ha cercato di trasmettere quello che
intendeva anche quando siamo andati alle Piatas in
Italia davanti a te, conosci migliaia di
persone a volte come potrebbe essere fatta
questa passione  mia figlia se la è cavata meglio
di me anche quando ci siamo presentati in
Parlamento fidatevi e lei è diventata più
complessa di me e questo è un bene
e ricordatevi tutti i miei libri tutti i
profeti vanno all'ospedale sindaco per i
bambini molto malati ed è molto importante
per me  è una passione fare qualcosa di
buono per le persone passione per gli animali una
mia grande passione e ho lavorato cercando di
salvare, conosci molti animali, soprattutto
animali marini, ho un
certificato di subacqueo professionista da molti anni
e questo mi permette di lavorare in determinate
operazioni che non  molte persone sono
ammesse ed eccomi qui a salvare le tartarughe
che sono state gravemente ferite e il bambino era
sotto shock e ho una grande passione per gli squali Adoro gli
squali come posso mostrarti questa
passione che ho per gli squali anche se ti mostro
una foto beh non lo fai  non vedi la mia
passione o pensi che questo ragazzo sia pazzo
beh questa è la passione per te ti fa
impazzire ricorda che domina una persona e
conosci anche la passione per gli umani ho
lavorato per tre anni come paramedico,
sai correndo per Londra di notte,
sai  e cercando di salvare e aiutare le
persone purtroppo molte
volte non sono riuscito a farlo perché
quando sono arrivato non c'era nessuna partita che
potessimo fare e credimi stavo
arrivando velocemente la passione per le motociclette, il
blues e gli strumenti a Londra  questo non lo
sai
affatto le forze della passione questa è
un'altra mia grande passione e come
posso spiegarti e trasmetterti cosa
significa volare su questo bellissimo
animale la cosa più vicina che puoi essere ad
essere davvero un angelo in paradiso  Non posso
saperlo ma questa passione mi ha permesso di
diventare quello che sono il miglior
cameraman a cavallo del mondo probabilmente anche
perché nessun altro vuole farlo ma
sai eccomi qui ho creato una carriera
passione per le arti marziali grande passione  dei
miei, sai, ho iniziato quando avevo
10 anni e ho continuato a essere giovane.
Eccomi con la leggenda del Judo, il maestro Bruno
Carmeni, supervisionando mio figlio che fa
di nuovo un Timon e la passione per il kickboxing,
conosci la mia grande passione e
te  sai anche se ti mostro qualcosa sai
così vedi passione no
tutto quello che vedi è solo ginnastica questa non è
passione okay ma credimi è
così passione quando parli e
comunichi ma tutto quello che vedi anche se
hai un bellissimo pubblico lo è  sono solo un
ragazzo agitato quindi come posso trasmettere questa
passione e posso assicurarti di farti
sentire la passione in azione beh forse posso
straniero
[Musica]
domina una persona ricorda, ma la musica è
l'unico momento in cui sai che il testimone
può effettivamente sperimentarla  e sentilo
così sai passione quanti tipi di
passione abbiamo bene abbiamo
fondamentalmente due tipi di passioni
abbiamo la moda ossessiva e abbiamo passioni
armoniose la passione ossessiva è
quando la passione è una
preoccupazione eccessiva per un'attività mentre la
passione armoniosa è quando c'è  è
più equilibrio, sai
come posso dire, più equilibrio in una
relazione sana con tale attività, questo è
davvero quello che è, quindi c'è anche una
definizione negativa di passione, passione,
una è parzialità, partigianeria, sai
e mancanza di giudizio, sai che è stato
accecato dalla passione  era preso dalla
passione non riusciva a giudicare le cose per via
della sua passione o contrario quando vogliamo
sembrare imparziali diciamo bene soprattutto
passione lo dico senza passione beh
sai vediamo un po' cosa
realmente abbiamo passione per noi e invece
di  simpatie nel giudicare cos'altro
sai significa che sai e quando va
male passione ossessiva sai cosa
diventa bene ti dirò cosa
diventa purtroppo diventa
fanatismo
non ho bisogno di immagini per evocare cosa
significa questo lo sai  fanatismo o
estremismo militare questo è quando la passione va
storta così e ancora crimine delle passioni
abbiamo situazioni in cui definiamo passione
o omicidio per passione conosci la
passione del crimine conosci la passione emotiva e
così via il crimine viene commesso Nel
calore della passione bene  sai, a dire il
vero, questo è un linguaggio che non dovrebbe
essere usato dai giornali o da chiunque
altro perché sai che
stiamo intestando il nostro passato nel nostro
torneo mondiale in un codice penale sai
valutare le circostanze del
cosiddetto crimine di omicidio Hana  o passione
e lo sai nel codice Rocco e
in realtà non dovrebbe più essere così e sai che
grazie a Dio è stato effettivamente respinto nel
1981 e non abbiamo più questo tipo di
disposizioni
quindi non parliamo del tuo crimine
passionale come  se la passione può giustificare un
atto violento soprattutto contro le donne un
atto violento è un atto violento Punto fermo
Portare via la passione
passioni così armoniose l'abbiamo visto
in poche occasioni questo è quello che sento
è quello che ho e sai che le mie
passioni lo hanno permesso  di arrivare dove
non pensavo fosse possibile e puoi farlo anche tu,
ma devi agire, sai che
finirai in alto nel mio caso, letteralmente io sono
davvero in alto, sai perché la mia
passione per gli sport estremi, sai,
mi ha sempre dato  quell'adrenalina che spinge
la motivazione ad andare più in alto che posso,
letteralmente a volte sai sciare o sai fare
Judo o macchine e moto profonde o veloci
in tutti i modi
cercando sempre di trovare una prospettiva diversa
e quella era la mia passione che mi commuoveva  e
questo è quello che dovresti farti sai che
è un'azione ecco cos'è la passione
quindi sai che mi ha portato delle grandi
soddisfazioni nella mia carriera e sai anche
una delle più grandi soddisfazioni del
mio cavalierato di cui sono molto affezionato
grato agli italiani e al mio
bellissimo paese, quindi la passione aiuta a
soddisfare i nostri bisogni, i nostri desideri e
sai, è un'energia così forte ed
è un tocco di forza potente che ci permette
di darci uno scopo questo è ciò che
fa la passione, questo diverso tipo di  le passioni che
conosci spingono le persone verso le loro diverse
attività e sai che nel mio caso è successo
così e c'è una buona notizia
sai che non devi sapere
qual è la tua passione, lo sai ma quello che
devi fare è andare e  trovalo
molto importante devi uscire e
cercare la tua passione se non sai di cosa si tratta
perché sai che la troverai
assicurati di fare un viaggio per
scoprirla che è davvero molto
importante e la
passione che conosci come  Ho detto che è una
forza forte e dà una motivazione
mi ha motivato a lasciare casa e sai
andare in un altro paese senza
nemmeno parlare la lingua e sai
che ha una funzione protettiva sì, lo
sai quando i tempi sono difficili, lo
sai  per esempio nel mio caso, quando ho perso
mio padre
un paio di anni fa, è stato un momento molto difficile
per la mia famiglia a causa delle
circostanze, mi ha davvero aiutato
perché andavo dai miei cavalli e sai che
la mia passione per i cavalli mi ha mantenuto sano di mente in
quel momento molto triste  e sai
aiuta le persone che hanno
disturbi mentali sai e sai che aiuta davvero
la passione in tutti i sensi e lui ti aiuta a
saperlo perché la passione ti fa fare delle cose
a volte uh mettersi in
discussione
[Musica]
sì e ha anche qualche
connotazione negativa perché  Sono senza fiato
ma ti ho fatto ridere quindi vedi che la passione è
molto potente e sai che dipende dal
livello che puoi avere ma è
importante perché ti spingerà a fare
ogni tipo di attività e sai che
questo è ciò che ti appassiona  sui
mezzi
e c'è un'ultima
cosa che voglio dirti la
passione non ti rende stupido beh
mi ha fatto diventare stupido lo sai qualche secondo
fa
che non ti rende stupido perché
lasciami provare a spiegarlo
devi fare qualcosa perché
stimi che accadrà qualcosa qualcosa di
molto importante okay usi il cervello
usa la parte razionale
e sai che non va come
volevi o perché l'hai
sopravvalutato o l'hai sottovalutato
beh ti senti piuttosto stupido vero
ma pensi  a riguardo se hai scelto di
seguire bene il tuo cuore
puoi sempre dare la colpa alla tua passione
puoi grazie mille
Marino de Angeli e
ehm
grazie